why go out and spend thirty thousand
dollars to make this movie that might
only make a few hundred dollars you know
why don't i just get a camera and set it
up and you know start doing youtube
videos
jay you had a great question we talked
about in between takes
yeah so i've been thinking about this a
lot lately i was like in today's in
today's day and age like
can we have
or could we have like a new filmmaker
like like quentin tarantino like in the
90s that making that kind of cultural
impact with an independent film like the
way reservoir dogs did and i've been
thinking about this a lot and like
racking my brain trying to even think of
a movie in the last 10 years
that came out from an independent source
and had that kind of cultural impact
that launched a director like that where
even before pulp fiction you know he was
a rock star like
can we have that today
and i i don't know because like i was
thinking like the closest to it in the
last like five years might be the
saffidah brothers but again not like
tarantino i mean my mom
knew quentin tarantino you know
my mom didn't know the saffini brothers
you know what i mean it just it i think
today with the proliferation of
streaming and just all of the content
and kind of you know our disposable
society whatever you want to say but i i
i don't know that a filmmaker no matter
how good that you could make a movie as
good as revzilla dogs there's definitely
people that are as talented as him out
there
that you know are making their first
movies but can those movies
have the kind of impact that something
like that had or that slacker had or
that clerks had
can we have that today and i i
i would say no it would be my my honest
opinion is i i don't think so i'm not
it's not impossible someone may totally
come out and shock me this year but i
don't think so it seems more
that the way things are working now are
like like the safety brothers where like
how many movies did they make before
like we knew who they were
you know a few you know and they they
built up to
you know a heart hard time or good time
and uh and uh
uncut gems they built but they had like
what two or three movies before that i
thought so something something like that
the spirit awards and i i think they
might have been were they like youtubers
or something before that i i don't know
i'm getting off but but what i'm saying
is they didn't just come out with a
movie that like boom here we are like
like and who has in the last 10 i i
can't think of anybody i'm sure people
will in the comments but i can't think
of anyone
right and maybe because there are more
people trying and also keep in mind we
have these influencers now and nothing
against them but
people who just look good and are
creative and do some really cool
instagram posts or whatever that's also
competing i mean we're just in this new
realm where there's so many people
competing for our attention yeah whereas
at that time
the 90s yeah well and also
not only do we have more people doing it
there's more people doing it like on a
professional level like even if they're
not even if they're just some youtuber
from toledo like they have a nice like
4k camera they got their lights set up
like it looks like like a pro
like tv broadcast from from the 90s you
know whereas in the 90s
you know like to make a movie look as
good you know sound as good and play as
good as roswell dogs that did it cost
about a million dollars where you could
do that today
for you know a couple hundred thousand
you know maybe less
sure and we were getting our information
from
gatekeepers for lack of a better term
and we were going to blockbuster and
seeing maybe just a few copies of
something versus
um harry met sally on the wall nothing
against harry met sally but yeah
20 copies of that and then
you know a few of these indie titles
that were harder to find
and so
those were there was just a limited
place for us to find them limited amount
of you know cameras weren't you know
readily available like they are now yeah
so there might just be more tarantinos
but maybe they're buried in the noise
yeah i i think so which which brings up
a you know a bigger point you know about
distribution and how today it's like
it's never been easier to get
distribution it's just now there are so
there's so much more content in the
marketplace that the individual value of
those movies has dropped you know so a
movie
like you know if you make a horror movie
today at fifty thousand dollars and you
made that exact same horror movie five
years ago for fifty thousand dollars the
five years ago one is going to be worth
you know whatever 100 or 200 000 whereas
the one today no matter how it turns out
is you know 75 100. you know it's just
less it's just worthless you're making
less you know like they talk a lot
people talk a lot about amazon dropping
rates but it's it's happened
all over the all over the place you know
dvd is shrunk we're not making as much
on dvd deals we're not getting ngs as
much we're making
platforms
distributors you know buyers they are
paying less for movies than they were
you know until you get into the
the studio range
sure and so and two when there were
these special films let's say a
basketball diaries
they were so special because there
weren't that many like them yeah now
there's so many amazing films with
sundance and all these other festival
you know there's all these indie
filmmakers so there's so much to compete
but when you had the one basketball
diaries then everybody could focus on
that one yeah and there were all these
you know so i don't know if that's a
relevant point but i think it is yeah
there's just so much i mean they say the
same thing about you know the home
recording uh industry as well
do you think that talent is no longer
attracted to independent film
i think there are a lot of things
competing for attention with independent
film now
and and honestly like independent film
or indie film it's such a like nebulous
like broad term and filmmaker is such
you know a broad term like like is
you know a youtuber that's you know
that's doing you know vlog videos you
know with lights and a camera and sound
are they a filmmaker
yeah you know but yeah i think that all
of those things are
like there seems to be a lot of more
easier routes
to money now you know like people see
the influencers you know like single
camera vlogs or just you know on their
phones and they're like
why go out and spend thirty thousand
dollars to make this movie that might
only make a few hundred dollars you know
why don't i just get a camera and set it
up and you know start doing youtube
videos
and some people are attracted to that
and i do think that
like some people that might have
you know like tried independent
filmmaking like like narrative films or
documentaries might get sidetracked into
that like like i've invented me i mean
i've made films for 20 years and you
know about five years ago i started
doing youtube videos you know and for me
it's uh you know it's an extra thing but
if i was starting out all over again i i
might have started there
and you're offering value to people
you're not just quote unquote talking
about yourself you're giving them tips
that could help save them down the line
and interviewing people totally totally
i mean i've always so at least in the
last few years i've been really focused
whether it's my movies or my youtube
channel and you know it's my i've said
it before it's my mantra over and over
what value am i adding what am i giving
people that they need or want
you know and i think that that has led
led me to doing better